the best way to predict your future is
to create it not from the known but from
the unknown what thoughts
do you want to fire and wire in your
brain highly successful people that are
trained are trained to stay calm
so they can respond you see the thing
about a master
is she never thinks she's a master the
thing about a professional is
he always thinks like an amateur and
what i mean by that is
you want to maintain this lunch box
mentality
want to be happy build a life not just a
[Music]
business
[Music]
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one
challenge that is holding you back a
lack of belief
in yourself you watch these videos
because you know you've got something
more inside you
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn how to
change your behavior to change
your life enjoy
okay let's kick it off with change
number one reward the effort with andrew
huberman
growth mindset which is the academic
discovery and laboratory discovery of my
colleague carol dweck at stanford is the
hallmark of growth mindset
is really two things one is i'm not
where i want to be now but i
but i will i'm capable of getting there
eventually
the other is to attach a sense of reward
to the effort process itself
in fact don't reward the result reward
the effort that's right and if you look
at
true high performers people that are
consistently good at what they do they
don't peek and go through the
postpartum depression and crash and come
back and their life is a cycle of
ups and downs but really people who are
on that upward trajectory consistently
those people attach dopamine to the
effort process
and actually carol's one of her original
studies on the discovery of growth
mindset was these kids
that loved doing math problems that they
knew they couldn't get right
so it's like the people love puzzles but
in this case they knew they couldn't get
it right but they loved doing it and it
incidentally or not so instantaneously
these kids are fantastic at math when
there is a right answer because
they're they feel some sense of reward
from the effort process
change number two create your world with
dr joe dispenza
your body is your unconscious mind in a
sense
if you're sitting down and you start
thinking about
some future worst case scenario that
you're conjuring up in your mind
and you begin to feel the emotion of
that event
your body doesn't know the difference
between the event
that's taking place in your world our
world and what you're creating by
emotion or thought alone
so most people then they're they're
constantly
reaffirming their emotional states so
when it comes time
to give up that emotion they can say i
really want to do it
but really the body is stronger than the
mind because it's been conditioned that
way
so the servant now has become the master
and the person all of a sudden once they
step into that unknown they'd rather
feel guilt
in suffering because at least they can
predict it being the unknown
is a scary place for most people because
the unknown is uncertain
people say to me well i can't predict my
future
i'm in the unknown and i always say the
best way to predict your future is to
create it
not from the known but from the unknown
what thoughts do you want to fire and
wire in your brain
what behaviors do you want to
demonstrate in one day
the act of rehearsing them mentally
closing your eyes
and rehearsing the action the rehearsing
the reaction of what you want or
the action of what you want by closing
your eyes and mentally rehearsing some
action
if you're truly present the brain does
not know the difference between what
you're imaging and what you're
experiencing
in 3d world so then you begin to install
the neurological hardware in your brain
to look like the event has already
occurred now
your brain is no longer a record of the
past now it's a map to the future
and if you keep doing it priming it that
way the hardware becomes a software
program and who knows you just may start
acting like a happy person
change number three always calm down
with john assaraf
hey it's john and i'm sure you've heard
of
this quote right here it is mindset
is what separates the best from the rest
mindset is what separates the best from
the rest but what does that
really mean when
astronauts are faced with a predicament
when they're outside of their
you know space station do they stay
calm or do they freak out
when navy seals are under water and
maybe they're being attacked
do they stay calm or do they freak out
when ceos face crazy
stress in their worlds because the
economy is shifting or interest rates go
up or the political climate changes
or something like the coronavirus
happens do they
freak out or they can't stay calm so
they can respond
i think you probably agree that
highly successful people that are
trained
are trained to stay calm so they can
respond
so the question is how do you train
yourself to stay
calm when there's chaos crisis
uncertainty
unpredictability and the answer is
you practice you practice staying calm
there's something that i learned
many many years ago called the razor's
edge and those razors edge
is that fine line between panic
and certainty panic and calm stress
and calm and what if
stress and anxiety and panic and
uncertainty and unpredictability was on
the right
side of this imaginary line on the
razor's edge
and calmness and certainty and
confidence and
focus was on the left side of this
imaginary razor's edge line
could you learn to focus on both could
you learn to flip-flop
between the two you see having the
mindset
of success a mindset of the best
doesn't mean that you don't see the
things that are
not working that you don't see the
crisis at hand that you don't
you know see you know all the things
that could go
wrong you do see it but you don't get
emotionally attached to it
instead you get emotionally attached
on focusing all of your energy and
attention on the solution
so a lot of people that don't do as well
in life as they could they're focusing
on the problem
the razor's edge that mindset
of the winners is recognizing and
knowing the problem exists
but taking your energy and attention on
solving the problem some people think
of what's happening in the world and
that's happening
to them and other people say here's
what's happening in the world
here's how i'm going to navigate through
this so that i become stronger
i achieve the goals and dreams that i
want and they have this relentless
pursuit towards how i can
because i must versus why i
can't and this
is the razor's edge this is where
mindset really does separate the
best from the rest it's not skill
there's a lot of people with skill who
get focused and sucked into the problem
and there's other people that recognize
the problem
and then flip and find the solution
the faster you are able to see both
problem
and solution and then take action on the
solutions
the faster you start to train your mind
to see
both and then focus on what it's going
to take
for you to do for you to feel and how
you need to behave in order to win
no matter what i don't care whether it's
financial success you want relationship
success you want health success you want
it makes no difference
the people who succeed the five percent
focus on solutions they focus on that
razor's edge that separates
the best from the rest hey this is john
asref and do you love good books
i love to read because there's so much
wisdom in books
you get to take somebody else's
knowledge skills research
pay 15 20 bucks and you learn so much
now i'm reading this awesome book called
built to serve
find your purpose and become the leader
you were born to be and one of my
new friends really smart guy really
great guy who serves a lot of people
evan carmichael
wrote it and i'm going to read a little
bit from
chapter number one and um
i love this piece and maybe it's because
i just watched
the series on tv on michael jordan the
last dance which is really great by the
way also
one of the things he says here is
everybody has
michael jordan talent at something
everybody has a michael jordan talent at
something you just haven't found it yet
or you have and you don't believe
in yourself enough to go all in
to go all in right and you're a genius i
believe you're a genius
and so does he you're amazing you were
not meant to live
a photocopy of someone else's life
you were not created to wake up and do
work that is below your capabilities
you have michael jordan level talent at
something
and you need to uncover exactly what
your purpose is
and how you can serve and use the serve
so lots of pearls and gems and
motivational
pick up built to serve evan carmichael
rising star change number four concern
yourself with
aliveness with sadguru who you are right
now
the most significant aspect is you and
me are alive right now this is it
what i'm thinking what you're thinking
is not the important thing
we are alive right now that is the
important thing
so it is important that you focus on
this fundamental sense of aliveness
within you
and then you will see there is a natural
distance between you
and your thought process once there is a
distance between your
psychological process and your
physiological process
this is the end of suffering because
there are only two kinds of suffering
that human beings go through physical
suffering and mental suffering
once you create a little space between
you and your mind between you and your
body
this is the end of suffering this is
something every human being has to
experience and know otherwise thinking i
will just remove
negative thoughts and i will have
positive thoughts all the best it's not
going to work
100 it's not going to work because
nobody can remove it they can avoid it
for some time
so when negative thoughts come you say
ram ram shiva siva whatever you want
but this is just avoiding it's not gone
the moment you stop that it will pop
back with great force
otherwise it will come back in your
dreams so it's very important
first of all you need to understand your
anger
your resentment your fear your anxieties
the negativity that you generate
generally resentment
anger it is always directed towards
somebody
but we need to understand this is
poisons that we are drinking
and expecting somebody else to die
fortunately life doesn't work like that
if i drink poison i die
if i drink poison you don't die so
we need to understand this when i say
poison today you can have yourself
chemically analyzed
right now what is your blood work what
it says five minutes of intense anger
check your blood work and see there will
be lots of negative elements in it
literally you're poisoning yourself so
do you want to poison yourself
definitely not now the very question is
coming from certain helplessness what
shall i do
don't do anything just sit back
and just concern yourself with something
which is a life process maybe your
heartbeat
maybe your breath may be just a
sensation of being alive
depending upon how sensitive or how
perceptive you are accordingly
find something it could be a sensation
in the body
it could be breath it could be heartbeat
it could be anything
something which indicates life to you
just pay attention to that for some time
slowly you will see there is a
distinction between what is you
and what you have gathered which
includes both your
physiological and psychological
possibility or mess whatever you made
out of it
change number five think like an amateur
with robin sharma
you see the thing about a master is she
never thinks she's a master
the thing about a professional is he
always thinks like an amateur
and what i mean by that is you want to
maintain this lunchbox mentality
you want to be boots on the ground
relentless
learning a humble servant of
your craft because the moment you think
you're an executive
or a master you start to lose the very
winning formula that made you
so successful and i think bruce
springsteen you know bruce springsteen
he's been performing for decades and
decades and yet if you have ever seen a
bruce springsteen show
he brings it on versus mails it in
and so i'm going to challenge you with
great love and respect as i always want
to do in these mastery sessions
but are you still maintaining that
lunchbox mentality like
the laborers carrying the lunchbox when
they go to the job site
are you still hungry you still have a
fire in your belly
do you still go the extra mile for your
customers do you still
go the extra mile for your organization
or you're just showing up
i mean for me i've been teaching
leadership and personal mastery
for almost two decades and i really
believe i am a laborer
i'm a i'm a plumber of high performance
you know i really feel like a laborer
i roll up my sleeves i still get
dirty i still deconstruct the way i do
things i in my meditations in my
journaling i do my very best to come
from a place of utter humility
and service you know and
i see myself with that lunchbox
mentality and i'm not perfect
but i encourage you to maintain that
mindset because it is
part of what will keep you at a level of
mastery
not only in your work but in your
personal life and change number six the
last one before a very special bonus
clip
is shift your mindset with lisa nichols
in order to reset your mind to think
abundantly or to live abundantly you
first have to
identify where are you currently
thinking in scarcity
which we don't like to spend any time
there because it's not fun
so and you can't to me one of the number
one
ways to avoid to
in a sexy way avoid transformation is to
generalize too much
like oh my life oh your life is so big
what areas of your life are you
currently thinking in scarcity
oh in my relationships what part of your
relation there's four different types of
relationships
there's romantic there's family there's
colleague and there's community
and what areas my finances what kind of
finances your income or your outflow
your debt management or your wealth
building
so number one the number one you push
past a limiting belief system
is that you identify where it's limited
and you it's almost like going to the
doctor saying doc
my left arm really hurts he's not just
going to start working on arm he's going
to say where
well you know the upper part well where
in the upper part
well over here between the elbow and the
shoulder well where between that like
doctors will ask you so many detailed
questions so that they can go exactly to
where the pain point is
and relieve the pain treat your mindset
that way as well
so when you're reaching for a more
abundant way of thinking
start by saying what frame of thinking
what mindset what part of my mindset
what belief system must i evict to
create space
let me give you another example your
hand your hand can only hold on to so
much
right so if your hand is already full of
limiting thoughts
i'm not good enough i'll never have
wealth
money is difficult to create i'm always
going to be overweight
people can't be trusted if your hand is
already full with limiting beliefs
how can you dare hold on to an abundant
way of thinking so first
let's dismantle this truth let's
dismantle the truth that money is hard
to make
so in the past i made money hard to make
money
is abundant there's enough for all of us
money is simply a tool
money is just dirty paper it's a team
member money is not the end-all money
gives you access to better memories okay
great let's work on that
and now let's work on i'll always be
broke or whatever the mindset is
right and the reality is no if you want
to have more money coming in or you want
to have more money in your bank account
then keep more than you spend so how can
we do that so you have to be willing to
be mildly to moderately to significantly
inconvenience possibly in order to keep
more than you spend
possibly or you want to grow your top
line and get more revenue
you want to create you might lose a
little sleep you might not be able to go
out to as many parties
you might not be able to spend as much
on your clothes but you want to bring in
more than you spend
so financial struggle is not imminent
now i'm not saying it's not difficult at
times i've been there
but it's not imminent it's not your
destiny so
notice how i can go and i can dismantle
each belief system
even if you don't believe this new truth
yet
which i've given you plenty of exercises
around adopting a new mindset
you can't visit a new mindset you gotta
go to a new mindset
you gotta park and you gotta constantly
revisit that mindset called possibility
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
it's time for the question of the day
i wanna know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video and
your plan of action for the next week
when you watch a video and you just get
motivated
the sign says you have a 35 chance of
actually following through
that's not good enough believe nation we
got to take action but
when you get motivated and then you
create a specific plan of action for
when
and how you're going to do it your
number jumps from 35
to 91 percent chance of following
through and when you commit to somebody
else
like posting down here in the comments
below that number jumps to 95 percent
i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week
put it down in the comments below so you
can follow through and i can celebrate
you
i'm going to give you the most important
strategy that the next time you're
feeling frustrated you're feeling
defeated you're feeling like giving up
will save you and help you find that
inner strength and next gear
here it is tell yourself it's the best
the next time you're feeling down
frustrated depressed
angry tell yourself it's the best
because now this is your chance to show
yourself
and the world what you're made of the
next time you're stuck at a red light
and you're frustrated complaining
it's the best the next time you're
working out and you feel like you're on
your last scene your
your lungs are on fire and you can't
push again it's the best the next time
you're frustrated in business that
you're not getting the sales you need
and you feel like you're waking up every
day and there's no momentum
it's the best it's the best this is your
chance
this is your chance you can complain for
seven and a half seconds
and get frustrated and then tweak it
inside your brain to say
this is the best why what does it do
first it switches your mindset to one of
hopelessness
to one as resourcefulness it switches
your mindset
from one of hopelessness that this sucks
that i'm giving up i'm defeated it's
over
why this is happening to me why does
this suck to one of resourcefulness that
this is the best
this is my chance because you grow
through challenges and this is the next
challenge in front of me
that i am going to grow through
if you want to know the mindset of high
achievers check out the video right
there next to me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there you know
the way and they think i'm gonna go
convey some magics here's the dust go go
go
it doesn't work that way i still grind i
love to grind